[Music]
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me what's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not
it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
oh yeah
eddie you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be
us hey i'm happy for you no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
i say either yeah either
i say neither can i say neither
either neither neither let's
call the whole thing off
excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
personal mrs chen he says hi one is the
loneliest
you and i are the same
[Music]
every decision we ever make
who do we leave behind and how
do we leave them waiting
in the darkness of the rescuer who never
comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
soon come chaos
chaos
[Applause]
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no
no you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing
[Music]
you